[Musique]
le québec compte plus d'une centaine de
vignobles on sait que l'on peut produire
d'excellents wable mais pour les rouges
c'est une autre histoire ya cinq ans
j'ai sorti un guide qui s'appelait guide
des vins et fromages du québec et
j'avais de la difficulté à cibler dix
vins rouges
jessica harnois et ronald georges
viennent tout juste de publier des
guides je l'aurais jamais fait avant
2013 l'europe au fait si le rouge avait
pas et s'était pas beaucoup mais
améliorées il constate maintenant que
les vins rouges québécois ont gagné en
qualité
et là on voit si on écrit un ouvrage
c'est parce que justement le rouge
reprendre l'expansion le québec je suis
très fier d'être si j'y crois à 100
milliards aussi le conseil des vins du
québec a créé il y a dix ans
l'appellation vin du québec certifier
les vignerons en ont profité pour mettre
en commun leurs savoir faire
on savait pas trop se donner une
direction de vignobles québécois parce
qu'on tirait à gauche qu'à droite et on
partageait pas on travaille pas ça c'est
pour protéger des oiseaux qu yvan
quirion est convaincu nous avons un
terroir et des conditions similaires à
d'autres grandes régions productrices
ici ça ma bourgogne
ça sent la nouvelle zélande l'ontario la
vallée d'okanagan
mais la différence ce sont nos hivers
québécois les vignerons se sont aperçus
que peu importe le cépage il n'utilisait
pas les bonnes techniques pour protéger
la vigne du froid et faisait du vin avec
des raisins qui n'atteignait pas leur
pleine maturité
mon a réalisé collectivement très
rapidement qu'on produisait sur le
bourgeon secondaire parce qu'on sût
belle subissaient des dommages sur le
bouchon s'expliquer la qualité moindre
de certains lui à particules bojan
climat vous voyez à 45 degrés et ua par
dessus le bourgeois secondaire mais le
second donne des beaucoup plus petites
grappes voyait différence les vignerons
donc corriger le tir et leurs efforts
ont porté fruit
y'a pas de raison si c'est pas bon ça
faute du vigneron de la vigneronne c'est
pas faute du climat
reste maintenant à convaincre les
consommateurs on n'ose pas toujours
goûter aux vins du québec parce que nos
parents nous ont dit que c'était pas bon
ils ont ramassé noces on aller pour
s'acheter une maison dans 30 ans si les
plus 50 ans ont souvent tu eu de
mauvaises expériences avec les vins
d'ici
les plus jeunes eux n'ont pas de
préjugés ils rentrent à boutique ya gep
et deviennent des ambassadrices des
ambassadeurs extraordinaires ici ont
validé dans le champ et en confiance les
locaux j'ai confiance en toi
des récits pas et fidèle
qu'est-ce que ça goûte pas ce que ça
goûte le québec compte ça goûte c'est
pas pour moi les québec c'est un peu
canneberge assez du lait bonne tenue de
gauche ferait opulent j'étais capable de
pouvoir justement goûter tomber et
goûter une bague et c'est ça pour moi
les mains rouges du québec vieux pour
mettre le québec sur la rue mainguy mais
la map des vins du monde
il faut qu'on parle plus de serre ou non
deux experts nous présente certains
produits qui décrivent bien la nouvelle
génération de vin rouge
c'est plus voluptueux quimper c'est très
mûr c'est bel assist est vraiment l'hôte
des gens voient ce qu'on appelle la robe
est beaucoup plus foncée sinon un peu
plus costaud avec des arômes on n'est
pas dans le fruit
on a dit oui on a des arômes un peu
animal rustique
tu vois le tango sont hostiles une autre
direction
il faut cuisiner avec ça peut être une
pièce de viande en sauce puis le chat
botté
c'est donc le fruit une touche de bois
plus séduisant mais rien de grossier du
show qui s'affiche sur multi vanille que
les amateurs de vins californiens
bordeaux vont pouvoir vraiment se
retrouver avec ses lacets domaine saint
jacques simoneau cépage pinot noir très
bon très droit très frais beaux fruits
canneberge
ça c'est la boîte est vraiment bien fait
ses droits l'alcool est intégrée hip hop
show à l'ipo choix dans la gorge
donc je me dis qu'il est agréable c'est
franc matin tu sais pas il ya dix ans
c'est le début d'une nouvelle ère pour
le vin rouge québec aussi ont réussi à
être focus et qualité et fidèle et
honnête vis-à-vis les clients on a un
bel avenir pour plusieurs décennies
et au prince 30 à les voir aller leur
parler aux vignerons aller voir sur
place voir comment ils travaillent
comment le vignoble et organisé vous
n'allez pas le regretter parce que vous
allez vivre une expérience en même temps
[Musique]